[Musique]
tu donnes vous avez vu vrai lit quand
vivent en paix vous l'avez gagnée il
s'attaque à un bel été de 2 elle était
tellement douce
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir excusez moi
mais ne craignez rien je suis là tout va
bien
ouais ça va mais toi vraiment vrai et je
dois courir
mais désolé et me suis laissé emporter
voilà j'ai entendu un cri la manne bonne
journée
[Applaudissements]
mon frère je
je suis tellement après toutes ces
années je fais enfin ma connaissance
et oui c'est lui ou que vois-je vous
devez être sa magnifique épouse
magnifique à arrêter j'aime mon frère a
pu trouver une femme comme vous arrivez
tôt
salut groupe comment se passe la
transition tu sais ton passage de pires
méchants du monde ap ir agents du monde
aux îles alors tu devais passer à la
télé c'était ton métier avant que tu
sois viré et ça pour quoi
oh les filles thomas dans ce quartier le
monde
[Musique]
haha
en gilet blanc je ne comprends toujours
pas pourquoi je viens pas avec toi et on
en a déjà discuté il y a un plan et
c'est pas le moment de tout changer bon
d'accord
[Musique]
coucou ce que je t'ai dit tu dois
attendre dans le bateau où je pensais
que tu voulais pas de 5 d'actes mans
avait voulu dire quoi d'autre il faut
qu'on trouve tu fais comme moi compris
ça va bien aller mignon me manque